Tom the market today is reacting to
what's going on okay a day two days
three days a week two weeks three weeks
four weeks
I'm gonna go strictly to you here do you
think if if I were to ask you the
chances of this happening with another
bank that's worth more than a hundred
billion dollars the 38 banks that are
worth 100 billion dollars or more what
is the likelihood of another bank or two
also going through this the next few
months give me the percentage what do
you think the percentages
you can say you know whatever percentage
if you're a betting man what do you
think it is well knowing what we know
um
and zerp for so long and such a level of
irresponsibility
I think it's probably about a 25 chance
you think that high
yeah oh my God I think there's probably
a 25 well here's here's it 25 chance of
like a run on the bank and everything
else going like this or do I think
there's a 25 chance that there's another
bank like signature that gets a tap on
the shoulder different question is there
another bank like signature that that
The Regulators are gonna like reel up
and say okay guys we gotta read those
freaking footnotes and we got to read
everything right now is there another
bank out there that they're gonna call
her like they did the New York other
bank no one knew about the southern New
York Bank it was an oh by the way point
in the Sunday news cycle right what's
this other big signature well what we
were talking to Silicon Valley Bank we
already knew this was coming and so we
kind of sent a couple of the boys over
there to kind of pull them into line so
do I think there's one more I think
there's a 25 chance that that's a more
pretty high number right there I think
that's a very high number yeah Barry I
think you may be a little bit more
conservative than that where are you at
so if you would uh there's a chart I
have that I'm gonna I'm gonna send
um I'm gonna send it to you uh to you
Pat I'm gonna I'm gonna text it to her
should I send it to Rob was that the
best way to go here all right I'm I'm
texting it to you it gives a scoreboard
so take a look at that I just texted it
to you rob
um I think if the FED did not step in
there'd be a hundred percent chance of
this happening but now that the FED
stepped in with this facility I think
that it is unlikely that it does happen
in my you know so I would agree if the
FED didn't do it very very yeah First
Republic jumping around on one leg now
exactly they're amputated one leg
exactly just to be clear here you're
saying there'd be 100 chance of another
bank I agree with them yes that's what
I'm thinking about I agree with them in
a way where
yeah take a look at that that's you
that's your school you know why you know
why he's why I'm on the side of what
he's saying right now if they don't do
anything about it because
what this decision did to the other
third 27th to the other 26 regionals and
the number of communities and all the
smaller Banks I as a depositor said it's
going to be fine yes the fdit FDIC is
going to step in but here's a question
just like we just found out what
percentage of depositors you think know
that the FDIC on their balance sheet
only has 125 billion to protect 9.9
trillion what percentage of depositors
in a marketing know zero I didn't know
that yeah we all didn't know that I just
learned right now myself so so that's
the part so you're 25 even with it
happening where are you at now that the
FED did step in but what would you be at
would you say five percent ten percent
yeah unlikely
um because I think there's facilities to
get you out of it
well I don't have no idea but I mean you
guys have a lot of credibility here what
I would like to avoid is sort of like a
self-fulfilling prophecy and be like
these banks are definitely going under
and then the narrative kind of starts
happening with that I like that the fact
that the government is stepping in and
ensuring people everything's okay right
why you were gonna if you were that I
thought you were gonna ask me
like do you know of one and I was going
to say First Republic but beyond that I
agree I think there's a lot of banks out
there right now that are trying to make
it right if they're not right and they
also know that the depositors are safe
because
grandma has put this thing out there 25
billion dollars in the btfp this let me
ask you guys a question Barry it's for
you so this is sort of a naive question
because I don't work on bank balance
sheets but
you know if you're a Chase if you're a
Goldman if you're at Wells a boa like
you're talking about the the Silicon
Valley Bank didn't have the the risk
officer or the risk manager even working
for the last eight months
these Banks I assume are like alert Red
Alert Red Alert like let's make sure
we're solvent like are there there's
protocols in place that banks are making
sure that they're good to go I I think
that uh hopefully that's something that
everybody is looking into and if if I
mean they probably already know where
all the bodies are buried right now I
think everybody else has this line of
sight to see that these investments in
supposedly risk-free assets that aren't
subject to the haircut because of uh of
the fact that interest rates have gone
up I think people are looking at what is
the percentage of loans that you have
that were at very low yields that Mark
to Market if Mark to market right now
how much would your actual
solvency B yeah and this goes back to
Pat's Four Points of capitalism and the
freedom to fail
and the metaphor of the entire 2008
crisis was what too big to fail so I'm
wondering with all this consolidation of
Banks and Pat's single we need more
competition in Banks what happens if one
of these massive Banks fails like what
happens to the U.S at that point well no
that that part is when others will come
in and pick them up for pennies on a
dollar right
you saw 308 312 whatever the number was
how much they were around they were
bought for buck nine billion nine that's
nothing right that's Pennies on a dollar
one went like this to Chase and how
uncomfortable is the CEO sitting right
here 34 months ago the most
uncomfortable meeting that we had
because he thought he was coming here to
talk about seven keys of success and we
talked about how the hell did WAMU one
of the biggest banks in America
go down the way it did so yeah that that
to me
you know there's a part where if you're
looking at this and whether you agree
with the decision or not
you you just have to make sure there's
not three or four other Banks out there
because if there is Tom FDIC cannot do
nothing it'll be another quantitative
easing 3.0 4.0 whatever you want to call
it super tarp and this time around it
will not be
a small number this time around it's
going to be a couple trillion dollars if
that happens again and the banks every
day and this has been part of plastic
eagle and a lot of other regulation the
banks at the end of each day have to
post to The Regulators uh balance sheet
with certain tests right and so there is
visibility out there that's why the
Regulators jumped in on Silicon Valley
Bank on not just a crashing stock price
they jumped in on because the run on the
bank it's actually they were almost kind
of blind to the public activity because
they look at the sheet at the end of the
day and they're like sweet Jesus you
know these guys are dead and The
Regulators can only jump in on the
regulatory violation and so that's when
it happened when there was a 42 billion
dollar request and then all of a sudden
they're negative 958 just under a
billion at the end of the day and
they're like okay not only have you flip
the circuit breaker you flipped all of
them you know and here we come
and so that happens every day so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]